we're the comics we're entertainers we
don't mean any harm
Jamie Fox weighed in on the fallout
following Kathy Griffin's controversial
trump photo at the launch of Prive Bravo
I wear his take don't kill the comedian
as comedians sometimes you do go beyond
the pastor line
I still love Kathy Griffin she went past
the line she'll pay for it in the way
she pays for it and we'll go out and
we'll laugh with her again I will say
this don't kill the comedian there's a
lot of people out here doing really bad
things and every time a comedian says
anything I set some about peanuts your
peanut shaming set some about dolphins
oh my god your dolphin with the comics
we're entertainers we don't mean any
harm
you guys got to stop it and a lot of
times I bling so do the social media to
things it's not the comedian's fault for
everything that's going wrong man trust
me the world is filled with people that
mean you harm and we sit and we give
them a pass eunsung saying so I know she
made a mistake or whatever and we're all
going to make mistakes but what you need
us man because we're there to make you
laugh
[Music]
you